so my name is Logan and Logan angstrom
and I'm a computer science major at MIT
and I'm going to talk about the
trade-offs associated with robust
machine learning so in machine learning
recently there's been an explosion in
the use of neural networks to do image
tasks and neural networks have
absolutely blown away the competition on
a bunch of standard image classification
tasks but they all suffer from the same
vulnerability of adversarial examples
adversarial examples are examples where
you take an input and then you perturb
it very slightly and to a human you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
between this original input and the
perturbed input but to an to the
classifier you totally fool it so for
example you can take a picture of this
pig you can add a little bit of
perturbation that looks like noise to a
human and that you can't even tell the
difference between this image in that
image actually and it turns out that
this image with the eyelid noise
classifies as an airplane instead of a
pig so this is a really big problem and
it's problem throughout all state of the
art image classification models and
there's been a huge line of work on
trying to fix this problem and it turns
out that the most successful methods for
fixing this problem for making networks
that are more robust also caused
classifiers to have a significantly
lower accuracy and then then just
training naturally and making a model
that has high accuracy but is not very
robust so what we set out to do is try
to figure out if there's really a
fundamental trade-off here or if we're
just not doing things correctly so we
start out with a theoretical model in
our theoretical model we essentially
show that there does exist a setting
where there's a fundamental trade-off
between accuracy and robustness and
there's a pretty natural model and this
statement is essentially of the form
that if you reach a certain amount of
accuracy you have to have at most this
amount of robust accuracy and vice versa
now we have this hypothesis we now move
on to actually verifying it in the real
world using classifiers that are
actually using the real world on real
world data sets we complete a bunch of
experiments to verify our hypothesis we
showed that in the large sample regime
if you try to make
classifiers are significantly more
robust than the naturally trained
classifiers then there is a fundamental
trade-off here at least in the
classifiers that we have today but in
the small sample regime you can actually
see that the making classifiers more
robust actually helps and it essentially
acts as a form of data augmentation to
make your classifiers even more even
more accurate but in large sample regime
we see the same predicted predictive
phenomenon that we saw in our
theoretical model and the large sample
dreams would really care about in the
real world now we have these problems
with with training these robust
classifiers but are they really problems
and is there a kind of a silver lining
here and so it turns out that these
robust classifiers are actually more
aligned with human vision in terms of
how they classify images and this makes
sense because you can essentially think
of robust classifiers as being more
invariant around in a very small l
2-norm ball around every single example
and in human terms that's basically like
you have some kind of image and then if
you add a very small perturbation to it
that human couldn't tell the difference
between then humans hawkmail tell the
difference like kind of tautologically
and so if we make it so that these
classifiers are more robust just around
the example then that means that they're
going to be more human they're going to
be more aligned with the way the human
vision works and we can actually see
this when trying to interpret the way
that these classifiers make decisions so
you can see here this is a beetle or an
insect and we're trying to classify it
as an insect or a dog or a cat or one of
any other labels and so in this with a
standard classifier that's been trained
without trying to make the classifier
robust the the heatmap of what the
classifier cares about basically looks
like noise and so you can you can you
can kind of see that there's like a
vague outline of a beetle but but if you
were to see those a priori you would
have no idea why this classifier is
making this decision but it turns out
when you add this robustness guarantee
the gradients become much more aligned
and that is the things the the parts of
the image that the classifier cares
about becomes significantly more aligned
with that humans actually care about and
so you can see here in this gradient in
this heat map of what the classifier
cares about you can see that the there's
essentially an outline
the beetle and you can see why this
classifier made this decision this is
the original example that we're trying
to classify this is the heat map of what
the standard classifier cares about this
right here is the heat map of what the
adversary trained robust classifier
cares about and you can see it's much
more light we have these experiments
about showing what happens when you have
large norm adversarial examples so this
is basically saying what happens if the
classifier what happens if we can make
adversarial examples that that can be as
far away as we want from from the
classifier and so from the original
firmly original input so instead of
making it so that the average of
examples has to be imperceptible from
the original image we're gonna make it
so they can be as big as they want it
turns out that when you make a large
norm adverse examples starting from this
guy with a Sarah classifier you
basically get the same monkey but when
you try to make the same adverse example
starting from this guy going to the l2
trained adversarial exam you actually
get something looks like a dog showing
that these classifiers to really fool
them you actually have to make images
that look like the the adversarial class
that you're trying to fool them with